back here hooking up with the UK London
connection will see our brothers
how are you
are you doing
[Music]
my drop of blood is felt but the Bosnia
that's mean that this is Bosnia I mean
know this river come here to Bosnia to
see and is still 20 30 years on and I
still see the bullet marks on the
buildings everywhere that I've gone and
and it's very sort of heartbreak
I mean really heartbreaking that this
these scars the physical stars
scars are still there and I mean
obviously it's a reminder for the people
who live here they see this every day so
how will they feel I mean our field side
and during that summer again you guys
correctly
sorry for what your name on Pakistan
class I would say the army started
digging in around here but not just one
ring of the three rings of artillery and
I was explaining these guys that the
colonel they were saying this is a
perfect textbook siege that even a
pigeon can't escape from here
right so they're three rings and so and
the story I was telling these guys now
and then during the summer tensions
arising and everyone said no this is
never gonna happen here what's happening
tomorrow doing to me and all this sort
of stuff and then okay but if you make
me safe with all these cannons should
they be pointing out the whole pointing
in right rights and then he said ah get
lost you know it's all basically and so
they they came up but there everyone was
realizing hang on this is something
wrong here and then besides 100,000
soldiers around there was about 60,000
people armed inside so they're arming
the Serb population here they brought in
Montenegrins and Russians and Romanians
all the Orthodox brothers
police in Michigan
haha good allaha prison attire yeah baby
son
nibel you get such all gig moving
muslima
never insane teach English aha
our am system Samoa Tanakh aloha budala
a prisoner here yet up in Isla
I've only get show
yes this is new this is called bosom of
the bursa municipality turkey has
sponsored this one so when they discover
this by John I think they were supposed
to build a road through here and they
found it like this
and then it was exposed and then they
they tracked it okay well now we've got
to build a road and there's a huge
protest blah blah blah and then they
kept it now like this is the uncle the
actual emperor whose ancient memories
didn't have kids and that's why fans for
he knows the air and this is a typical
this is a typical scene Austin Empire
you know the lot of muslims from bosnia
and software okay we'll go this way in
this place
serving criminals in the night of the
26th August 1919 to 1992 talks about
University library of Bosnia and has a
government over 2 million books
periodicals and documents vanished in
flame
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Sundra chair or readiness for sit
YouTube channel
oh yeah
[Music]
bismillah
[Music]
the questions over here
[Music]
best cabdriver had in Sarajevo it wasn't
full of smoke and wasn't blasting us
with the STD spiritually transmitted
disease music Hum Dil ah thank you said
I'll let go kept his eye
yeah
I mean come on now I think of you riding
the cab or anywhere I mean you're the
one paying for the service come on
listen to it okay I mean that's your
business but some people don't want to
listen to that kind of stuff so some
people would rather have a nice
conversation make the human connection
I've got a question real quick maybe you
guys can send me the sisters out there
and humanity can help with this one who
sets the standard who sets the transfer
let's say you work it in an airline
let's say that you're working for a
company and usually we're here the
common statement I don't want no man
tell me what to do
but if you had to choose my crater is
gonna tell me what to do
or a man is going to tell me what to do
because who sets the standards if you're
working for an airline for instance a
company whether the case and you just
don't fear feel comfortable having the
skirt above the knee okay so what if you
wanted to load the knee what if you
wanted to the shin what if you were
lower than that I mean who's to tell you
you can't do that because what's to stop
the man who's running the company this
is tomorrow they start setting the trend
they say look you got to bring that
skirt up towards the thigh and then from
there because we keep seeing to go up so
sisters think about this this is a
humanity think about that I'm asking
this seriously the the genuine sincere
question who says two strands I mean
who's the one says the standards I mean
do you really feel comfortable having a
man tell you what to do or would you
feel more comfortable when the most
merciful man you became the most loving
one who created you the one who wants to
dress you and the man wants to undress
you who would you rather follow just
something to think about and let us know